[Music]
this question of whether we are making
any real progress in the area of race
relations now there are some people who
feel that we aren't making any progress
as some people who feel that we are
making overwhelming progress I still
have the faith to believe that we shall
overcome before the victory is won some
more will get scarred up a bit for the
victories won some more will be thrown
into jail for the victors one then it
will be misunderstood and called bad
names simply because they are determined
to stand up I would like to take what I
consider a realistic position and say
that we have come a long long way in the
struggle to make justice and freedom of
reality in our nation but we still have
a long long way to go
[Music]
you